on se retrouve donc punchline est ce
soir notre invité c'est françois-xavier
bellamine bonsoir les soirées tête de
lice les républicains aux européennes
vous êtes enseignant en philosophie
maire adjoint de versailles également on
va évidemment parler de la restitution
du grand bé débat café edouard philippe
ce matin mais renoncer à une question
d'actualité qui vient de nous parvenir
le royaume uni fixe donc au 23 mai la
date des élections européennes que ça
veut dire qu'officiellement le break
site est reporté lamy non ça veut dire
que les britanniques étaient obligés par
les règles européennes d'organiser cette
élection parce que si jamais un accord
ne pouvait être trouvé avant la date de
l'élection européenne et si jamais une
sortie sans accord ne se réalisait pas
alors le fait que les britanniques en
étant toujours membre de l'union
européenne ne puisse pas participer au
parlement européen menacé tout le
fonctionnement l'union européenne ça ne
veut pas dire que le bric site est
repoussée ça veut dire qu'il faut que
les britanniques prennent leurs
dispositions au cas où le bric site ne
serait pas encore actée au moment de
cette élection c'est ce qu'ils disent
ils disent ronan église élections en les
élections en place mais on espère qu'on
né participera pas c'est à ne plus rien
y comprendre
c'est à ne plus rien y comprendre les
faits et maintenant soyons clair il faut
absolument parvenir à un accord
c'est la vision que nous défendons c'est
la vision de michel barnier aussi qui a
mené cette négociation qui est membre de
notre famille politique et qui depuis le
début
d'ailleurs avec l'accord unanime des 27
états membres de l'union européenne
quelle que soit leur couleur politique
mène cette discussion avec la volonté de
parvenir à un accord nous disons qu'ils
font quitte à reporter exceed c'est pour
trouver cet accord quant à 80 pour
l'instant notre sentiment c'est que tout
vaudra mieux qu'une sortie sans accord
parce qu'une sortie sans accord nous
avons le devoir de nous préoccuper des
intérêts des français
une sortie sans accord c'est 50% de la
pêche française qui risque de rester à
quai et derrière des dizaines de
milliers de familles qui seront impactés
par ce que c'est toute une filière qui
est concerné c'est des agriculteurs qui
risque de voir arriver sur le marché
unique des produits qui jusque-là à
l'est sur le marché britannique et qui
ferait probablement subir un choc des
prix à des filières déjà menacé c'est
pour les filières industrielles des
problèmes considérables bref tout plutôt
qu'une sortie sans accord mais il faut
un accord qui interviennent rapidement
et la balle est dans le camp des
britanniques 12
la dernière limite c'est le 12 avril
c'est la semaine prochaine exactement
on ne peut pas faire un geste pour
essayer tous une solution
il ya deux éléments vous savez le brick
city est assez complexe parce qu'au fond
on parle de plusieurs choses à la fois
il ya d'un côté l'accord qui parle du
divorce et la manière de rompre les
liens cet accord là il est d'une telle
complexité qu'il n'est pas possible d'y
revenir
en revanche ce qui est potentiellement
en discussion et c'est la vision de
michel barnier c'est tout ce qui
concerne notre partenariat futur parce
que les britanniques vont sortir de
l'union européenne il faut que ce choix
soit acté mais ils vont évidemment gardé
des liens avec l'union européenne
et c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il faut
pouvoir discuter cela étant dit encore
une fois aujourd'hui le geste il faut
qu'ils viennent des britanniques et les
britanniques ont parfaitement conscience
eux même que le problème c'est qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre entre eux
pour parvenir à une décision
cette situation n'a que trop duré il
faut évidemment arriver à une issue
on revient en france on va écouter le
premier ministre edouard philippe qui a
eu ce matin fait la restitution du grand
débat de ces heures de débat et de ses
contributions écouter le dire nous
devons baisser les impôts la première
exigence c'est en fait une immense
exaspération fiscale cette exaspération
ne date pas d'hier
mon gouvernement assume sa part de
responsabilité
il en a d'ailleurs tiré un certain
nombre de conséquences en annulant la
hausse de la taxe carbone mais bien
avant la hausse de cette taxe
cette exaspération avait atteint des
sommets dans toutes les catégories de la
population
notre pays a atteint aujourd'hui une
sorte de tolérance fiscale 0 c'est pas
si on peut l'appeler comme ça mais c'est
souvent comme ça qu'elle est exprimée
les débats
je le crois nous indique clairement la
direction à prendre
nous devons baisser et baisser plus vite
les impôts françois-xavier belem et vous
saluer la clairvoyance la lucidité du
premier ministre après tout ce temps
c'est une lucidité qui n'a que trop
tardé et qui nous a coûté assez cher
quel quel sujet d'étonnement comme je le
partage vraiment avec vous que le
gouvernement ait eu besoin de ce grand
débat qui a coûté 12 millions d'euros
qui a duré plusieurs mois de ce grand
débat pour savoir que les français
paient trop d'impôts
quelle chose incroyable que les gilets
jaunes se sont mobilisés dès le départ
pour dire leur refus d'une mesure qui
allait encore aggravé la fiscalité qui
pesait sur eux et que ce n'est qu'après
des mois des mois de chaos de désordres
et des mois de ce débat mise en scène à
grand renfort de communication qu'on
arrive au résultat final moi je peux
vous dire je suis en campagne depuis
deux mois j'aurais envie de dire au
premier ministre ou à des membres de son
gouvernement de venir en campagne avec
moi il suffit de passer 24 heures sur le
terrain pour savoir quels sont les
problèmes de la france est en deuil
aussi ses temps perdus ce grand débat
pour vous le fait d'avoir écouté les
français enfin une partie des français
je crois que les français avaient besoin
d'être écoutés et de ce point de vue là
il était nécessaire de donner ce temps à
l'écouté c'est une certitude absolue
ils ont besoin d'être entendus mais quel
malheur qu'on ne les ait pas écoutez
plutôt
quel malheur qu'on ne les ai pas
entendus plus tôt et quel gâchis qu'on
en arrive là seulement après ces mois
perdus en fait le premier ministre
découvre la lune nous sommes le pays
champion du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires et la pression fiscale et
c'est maintenant seulement qu' edouard
philippe découvre qu'il y a un problème
fiscal en france mais pardonnez moi en
2017 ce qui avait fait le coeur de
l'engagement de la droite dans
l'élection présidentielle c'était de
dire que nous avions un problème
ce problème ne date pas de monsieur
mâcon et il ne saurait être question de
lui en imputer l'entière responsabilité
bien sûr ce problème est le résultat de
30 années de déni et de fuite en avant
dans cette espèce de dans lequel vous
incluez le propre voyant ma droite un
plus qui est qui est au pouvoir
si vous voulez cela étant dit la droite
elle elle a tenté de faire baisser les
dépenses de l'état elle a eu à faire
face à une crise majeure sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
après deux ans qui était économiquement
infiniment plus favorable rien n'a été
fait pour résoudre ce problème
et malheureusement la question est
toujours devant nous heureusement le
prévenu qui se rendent compte mais on se
dit
quand même à caen à quand les mesures
concrètes annoncées par le président
vous vous proposez aux républicains une
baisse de l'impôt sur tous les salaires
ça une baisse de l'impôt souvenir pour
toutes les tranches bien sûr encore une
fois quand on est le pays champion du
monde de la pression fiscale
on ne peut pas continuer de vivre dans
cette situation où effectivement on
asphyxie sur le terrain la capacité
d'entreprendre d'innover d'investir au
fond on est devant une situation de
crise que nous provoquons nous mêmes par
nos propres blocage la france est
l'effet d' incroyable potentiel de
talents de compétences qui rayonne
partout dans le monde mais si nous ne
parvenons pas à nous déployer ac c'est
d'abord parce que nous nous pénalisons
nous-mêmes notamment du fait de ce poids
de la fiscalité la réponse à la demande
de justice fiscale des français vous
c'est on baisse les impôts même pour les
plus riches et les privilégiés c'est sa
baisse des impôts pour tout le monde et
d'abord pour les classes moyennes et les
classes moyennes qui sont au coeur de
cette situation parce qu'elles payent
pour entretenir le train de vie d'un
état qui n'a pas su se réformer mais
évidemment il faut baisser globalement
le poids de la fiscalité c'est une
nécessité absolue c'est un impératif
sens économique se sera pas facile bien
sûr il faut faire des économies d'argent
dans l'est dans le casse semble tout à
fait évident qu'il faut faire des
économies ça ne devrait pas échapper
qu'en 2010 est effectivement le projet
de la droite était un projet très
complet très précis très détaillée pour
faire en sorte qu'en faire notre pays
fasse les choix courageux qui l'attend
vingt cinq mille suppressions de
fonctionnaires proposée par françois
fillon
on peut re discuter du programme on peut
voir à quel endroit et comment et
quelles modalités doivent être celles
des choix que nous avons à faire mais ce
qui est certain c'est que nous ne
sortirons pas de la situation de crise
dans laquelle nous sommes en restant le
pays champion du monde là aussi le
champion du monde de la dépense publique
et de la dépense publique pour quel
résultat
ce que les français voient sur le
terrain et notamment lancé dans ces
territoires de la france périphérique
c'est que le poids de la fiscalité a
continué d'augmenter et que
simultanément la qualité des services
publics n'a cessé de se dégrader
on peut faire mieux avec moins et nous
sommes capables de le faire encore
faut-il effectivement faire ses choix
courageux qui nous attendent bien sûr et
victor vite une question monsieur
bellamy le 23 novembre dernier sur sud
radio vous disiez être de tout coeur
avec les gilet jaune vous regrettez
d'avoir prononcé cette phrase ou pas
bien sûr que non le neveu le 23 novembre
on était au tout début de ce mouvement
qui était encore un mouvement pacifique
un mouvement paisible et je crois que si
on en est arrivé à ce degré de violence
c'est aussi parce que ces gens qui
commençaient à occuper les ronds-points
en disant que cette pression fiscale les
étouffer
ces gens là n'ont pas été entendus on
leur a répondu qu'ils étaient la france
qui fument des clopes et qui roulent au
diesel
eh bien il ya un moment dans notre pays
où malheureusement je suis le premier à
le regretter mais et là aussi c'est un
problème fondamental qui nous concerne
tous
il ya un moment dans notre pays où les
citoyens ont entendu que si on ne cassez
rien on n'avait aucune chance d'être
écouté je le regrette évidemment je le
regrette profondément
et bien sûr je condamne sans aucune
ambiguïté toutes les violences qui ont
eu lieu et qui abîme évidemment l'image
de notre pays et de notre démocratie
mais ce qui est certain c'est que je
regrette d'abord que le gouvernement
n'ait pas été plus à l'écouté de ceux
qui disaient leur désespoir devant cette
pression fiscale qu'on voulait leur
imposer des agriculteurs qui ont besoin
de maîtres du gasoil dans leurs
tracteurs des ouvriers qui ont besoin de
mettre de l'essence dans leur voiture
pour aller travailler
tous ces gens-là qu'on aurait pu écouter
quand ils venaient paisiblement dire
leur désaccord devant cette taxe et qui
malheureusement ont été méprisés jusqu'à
ces déferlements de violence le
calendrier de ce grand débat on sait que
le premier ministre va faire la
restitution les trois prochains jours
puis le président s'exprimera la semaine
encore d'après est ce que vous pensez
qu'il fait durer le plaisir
et est ce que vous pensez qu'il va
enjamber les élections européennes en
égrenant ses propositions jusqu'à l'été
je constate une chose c'est que le
président de la république a lui même
dépassé le calendrier qu'il avait fixés
c'est lui qui avait donné des dates et
c'est lui qui est en train de les
dépasser et ce que je regrette
profondément
c'est que au fond nous payons avec ce
grand débat un débat présidentiel qui a
été manquée pour toute une série de
raisons cette élection présidentielle ne
s'est pas fait elle ne s'est pas faite
d'abord sur les grands choix qui
attendait notre pays elle s'est faite
sur des éléments de circonstances est
aujourd'hui le grand danger c'est que
nous manquions cette élection européenne
et le débat européen qui pourtant est si
nécessaire et je crois que ce serait
vraiment dommage il faut que le
président prenne la mesure de la
nécessité d'engager ce débat sur
l'élection européenne et qu'enfin il
nous donne ses décisions que nous
attendons bien sûr de voir avancer
sereinement
monsieur bel animateur l'instant être de
tout coeur avec les gilet jaune de
novembre pourrait-on dire la parole de
ces de ses premiers gilet jaune health a
incarné dans un élément qui est
aujourd'hui analyser ce sont les cahiers
citoyens les fameux cahiers de doléances
qui ont été spontanément rond pourront
remplie dans de nombreuses mairies le
consortium chargé de les analyser a
rendu ses conclusions
aujourd'hui il montre que en matière
fiscale
priorité qui se dégage de cette parole
que vous disiez vouloir écouter la
première priorité c'est effectivement et
diminuer la fiscalité sur les
particuliers notamment sur leurs
dépenses contraintes et la deuxième
priorité c'est la justice fiscale et
notamment des mesures de taxation sur
les hauts revenus et les grandes
entreprises
est ce que ça veut dire que comme vous
le disiez à l'instant il faut écouter
cette deuxième priorité
bien sûr il faut écouter les français
cela étant dit écouter les français ça
veut dire pouvoir leur répondre avec la
manière dont nous voyons les choses
écouter les français ça veut pas dire
être démagogue pour autant et c'est très
important de bien associer ces deux
éléments d'abord la première chose que
je voulais dire c'est que à ce grand
débat ont participé d'après les
statistiques du gouvernement lui-même un
peu moins de 1 % du corps électoral
on ne peut donc pas considérer que ce
grand débat vaille pour la décision des
français c'est l'expression d'une partie
du peuple français qui s'est
effectivement mobilisés mais d'une
petite partie seulement qui n'a pas
vocation à remplacer la démocratie
représentative qui s'exprime à travers
nos institutions
la deuxième chose c'est qu'à partir de
ces expressions les partis politiques
ont le devoir de présenter leur vision
des choses
ce qu'on attendait politique ce n'est
pas de se mettre immédiatement dans une
forme d'immédiateté précisément à
exécuter ce qui a été demandé de façon
ponctuelle ou parcellaire par les
français ce qui compte c'est que chaque
partie que chaque camp que chaque et
élus puissent développer sa vision
d'ensemble et moi ce que je regrette au
fond dans ce grand débat c'était déjà le
cas dans la lettre qu emmanuel macron
avait écrite au tout début
dans ce grand débat il avait commencé en
posant une série de questions séparées
mais ce qu'on attendait politique c'est
qu'il nous présente un projet d'ensemble
de ce point de vue là évidemment dans la
fiscalité
il ya une exigence de justice il ya
aussi un impératif d'efficacité nous
sommes déjà le pays au monde encore une
fois où la pression fiscale est la plus
élevée l'impôt sur la fortune nous le
savons a été pour notre pays l'occasion
de se tirer une balle dans le pied
pendant trop longtemps en faisant fuir
ceux qui dans notre pays avait les
moyens d'investir je ne crois pas et
c'est ma responsabilité début de vous le
dire je ne crois pas que ce soit une
bonne idée de rétablir l'impôt sur la
fortune
après que les français s'expriment au
moment des élections pour dire ce qu'ils
veulent exactement et nous défendrons la
vision qu'a droite nous partageons de
cette fiscalité pour demain on va parler
un peu de rap avec vue sur l'europe les
pays européens
ce bel ami se font concurrence à eux
mêmes est ce qu'à votre avis c'est
plutôt sympa ce que la concurrence
globalement c'est pas mauvais pour un
libéral et vous êtes libéral ou est ce
que on est en train de se détruire et
détruire l'europe à petit feu parce
qu'on a aucune politique commune est-ce
qu'il faut marquer un changement après
ces élections européennes comme me
semble-t-il le soin de le président de
la république y aller vers davantage
d'harmonisation et si oui jusqu'où il
faut bien sûr et un changement il faut
un changement parce qu'aujourd'hui cette
politique de la concurrence qui est
devenu d'une doctrine quasiment
exclusive en europe
elle contribue à nous fragiliser dans la
mondialisation au lieu de nous renforcer
on le voit dans notre rapport avec des
acteurs étrangers on l'a vu très bien à
l'occasion de ce dossier alsthom si
mince quand la commission en appliquant
le droit européen a décidé d'empêcher
cette fusion manifestement elle a
contribué à entretenir cette aberration
qui fait que nous sommes face à de
grands champions internationaux
largement soutenus par leurs états
respectifs largement monopolistique sur
leur territoire de départ est que face à
eux nous alignons nos entreprises
auxquelles nous interdisons la
possibilité de grandir et de s'unir face
à cette concurrence et donc nous
organisons nous mêmes notre impuissance
et puis c'est vrai aussi sur le marché
commun sur le marché unique au sein
duquel effectivement une simple doctrine
de la concurrence ne fait pas une
stratégie industrielle a progressé dans
la bonne direction et question annexe si
laurence le permet
la commission on en parlait à l'instant
à cause de ce refus dalton cima alstom
siemens est ce qu'on peut encore
continuer dans votre vision longtemps à
avoir une commission de technocrates
sympathique et sûrement compétent mais
nos élus et qui décide en lieu et place
des politiques
qu'est ce que c'est ça l'europe que vous
voulez vous ce que nous voulons c'est
faire en sorte que la commission
européenne ne soit plus une instance
spécifiquement dédiés à la production
des normes parce que font l'europe ne
s'est pas construite d'abord par des
normes les normes européennes elles
peuvent évidemment contribué à renforcer
l'europe dans un monde où la bataille
des standards est un enjeu important
mais il faut d'abord retrouver l'esprit
pionnier l'esprit d'une europe des
projets d'une europe qui puisse se doter
d'une vision stratégique a réduit le
nombre alors on peut tout à fait
imaginer avoir des blocs de coopération
quand sur certains sur certains sujets
tous les pays ne veulent pas avancer
eh bien il faut qu'on puisse libérer la
capacité de ceux qui veulent construire
ensemble prenons par exemple la question
des politiques de défense politique
industrielle en matière de défense tous
les états ne voudront pas y participer
parce que le poids de l'otan et plus
important par exemple chez les pays de
l'est et bien très bien
faisons en sorte que ceux qui veulent
travailler ensemble puissent déjà
avancer ensemble qui t'a donné envie aux
autres d'ailleurs de les rejoindre
ensuite mais ce qui est important sur le
point qu'on évoquait à l'instant c'est
que nous puissions sortir de cette
naïveté laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
et nous proposons d'imposer une règle de
réciprocité absolue dans les échanges
commerciaux avec les acteurs étrangers
nous voulons installer par exemple une
barrière écologique à l'entrée du marché
commun ou les pays qui importeront sur
le marché unique devront comme c'est le
cas pour les producteurs européens
contribuer à une taxe carbone qui
correspondra aux émissions de carbone
qu'ils émettent pour produire le bien
qu'ils importent ses bons plans pouvoir
d'achat des français ça ce qui est bon
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français ça
travaux ce qui pèse sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français aujourd'hui c'est
deux choses d'une part la faible
compétitivité de nos entreprises qui
perdent des parts de marché parce que
précisément nous leur tirons des balles
dans le pied et qui ce faisant
évidemment perdre aussi en capacité
d'emploi est ce qui pèse sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français
c'est encore une fois le poids de la
fiscalité aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
espèce de difficulté à considérer que
nous devons aux arrières écologique elle
finira par se retrouver sur les prêts à
la consommation et vous le savez
parfaitement mais avec ce raisonnement
là effectivement on continue de détruire
nos entreprises et nos emplois et je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est un
argument qui a été majeur
la doctrine européennes de la
concurrence on peut reconnaître que la
concurrence a fait du bien un pays comme
la france qui avait une tradition de
monopole d'état d'une certaine manière
et que l'union européenne nous a permis
aujourd'hui sans l'union européenne nous
aurions peut-être un seul opérateur de
téléphonie mobile
l'union européenne nous a permis de
sortir de certains travers mais la
doctrine de la concurrence elle a aussi
ses excès et d'une manière presque
philosophique je me permettrai dire que
le danger c'est que nous ayons si
longtemps favorisé le consommateur au
détriment du salarié la consommation au
détriment du travail ce qui nous
redonnera du pouvoir d'achat c'est de
retrouver une capacité d'entreprendre
une capacité d'initiative et de rayonner
de conquérir des parts de marché alors
vers l'autre question clé pour ces
élections européennes on va voir
d'ailleurs les intentions de vote c'est
notre sondage quotidien pour l'ifop
on voit que votre liste est à 13% la
république en marche 23% le
rassemblement national 20,5 pour cent
l'autre question majeure c'est la
question migratoire sur laquelle deux
blocs s'affrontent
emmanuel macron qu'a pris la tête du
bloc progressiste selon lui et puis les
nationalistes ou est ce que les
républicains vous vous situez est-ce
qu'il faut des quotas de l'immigration
votée au parlement
nous nous croyons à une politique qui
construit qui construirait une double
frontières pour mieux répondre aux défis
migratoires le défi migratoire il est
devant nous et non pas derrière nous
parce que la crise migratoire n'a pas
encore commencé la démographie du
continent africain peut nous faire
penser que si nous ne faisons rien nous
allons continuer de subir des flux
migratoires incontrôlés qui provoque
exactement les tragédies que nous
déplorons en méditerranée mais aussi les
tensions qui fracturent nos sociétés et
donc pour remédier à ce défi migratoire
et à l'ampleur de ce défi il faut une
politique européenne forte et ceci nous
distingue bien sûr du rassemblement
national qui par idéologie veut des
construire l'europe et qui au cours des
dernières années a voté contre tout ce
qui pouvait renforcer une politique
européenne en matière d'immigration
ils ont voté contre l'établissement des
contrôles systématiques aux frontières
et c'est vous et vos propositions qui
m'intéresse est présente au stade du ray
semble de très important parce que vous
deviez comparer à eux mais il ya deux
blocs qui s'affrontent
car en réalité il ya deux idéologies je
dirais qu'ils s'affrontent d'un côté une
idéologie qui nous fait croire qu'on
sera plus fort si on sépare de l'autre
côté une idéologie qui est celle du
président de la république qui voudrait
seulement gérer notre impuissance en
répartissant des quotas de migrants au
sein de l'union européenne
nous ne croyons pas à cette politique il
s'agit pas de gérer l'impuissance il
s'agit de faire en sorte que nous
puissions effectivement maîtriser nos
frontières pour accueillir vraiment mais
non pas pour subir ces flux migratoires
incontrôlés et nous défendrons donc le
principe de cette double frontières
défense des frontières extérieures de
l'europe avec le renforcement d'une
stratégie européenne en la matière et
simultanément veut dire quoi sa maîtrise
des politiques nationales en matière
d'immigration concret chamalières
détermine la double barrière
concrètement ça veut dire premièrement
c'est une chose très importante que nous
devons faire en sorte qu'en europe nous
nous mettions tous d'accord sur un
principe on ne peut entrer sur le sol
européen que si on a préalablement
demandé à entrer sur le sol européen
quand vous demander l'asile donc des
centres de rétention à l'extérieur des
frontières intentions des points où vous
pouvez demander l'asile dans des pays
tiers qui sont sûres sur lesquels votre
route vous même quand vous quittez votre
et qu'elle allait vers l'europe
tous les pays du monde qui sont des pays
sûrs quand votre pays est en guerre ou
en grande difficulté vous n'arrivez pas
directement à paris votre chemin vous
conduit la libye par exemple c'est un
pays en paix pour vous mais justement
pourquoi est-ce que la libye est
aujourd'hui le pays par lequel passe
temps de migrants abandonné au aux
filières de passeurs précisément parce
que nous n'avons pas su déployer une
vraie politique qui permettrait
d'instruire des demandes d'asile dans
les pays par lesquels passent au
préalable des personnes qui sont en 30
ans trajectoire en transit et qui en
quittant leur pays pourrait demander
l'asile
avant de se trouver en europe
aujourd'hui le principe de base c'est
qu'il faut arriver en europe et que
quand vous y est arrivé vous avez toutes
les chances d'y rester c'est ce principe
qu'il faut inverser
parce que si nous n'inversons pas nous
allons continuer d'alimenter des fois
être décidé ça vous une unanimité ou pas
regardez ce qui s'est passé qu'italie
celle d'annie à fermer des frontières
c'était violent et aidera maintenant
tout le monde
enfin beaucoup passent par l'espagne
exactement c'est la raison pour laquelle
le changement c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne croyons pas la solution
du rassemblement national il faut
absolument déterminés à 27,7 politique
migratoire efficace parce que sinon si
chaque pays est abandonnée à son sort
qui croit un seul instant que le défi
sera relevé qu'ils pensent que la grèce
pourra maîtriser ses propres frontières
nationales qui pensent que seul
chaque pays pourra mettre en oeuvre une
politique qui
nature a relevé l'ampleur de ce défi et
2 ce défi dépend l'équilibré du monde de
demain précise comme des âmes en ce qu'a
dit l'italie vous nous avez abandonnés
vous nous avez laissé en première ligne
avec les bateaux de migrants qui
arrivait résultat nous on ferme et
l'italie a eu raison bien sûr l'europe a
fait défaut à la solidarité qu'elle
devait au peuple italien et c'est parce
que nous lui avons tourné le dos que
l'italie connaît aujourd'hui la la la la
réaction que nous lui voyons que nous le
voulions adopter
il faut donc absolument que nous
puissions mettre en oeuvre une politique
commune sur ce sujet sinon comme le dit
enrico letta qui est un grand européen
sinon nous aurons 27 brixi chine aussi
en europe
la gouvernance européenne si quelqu'un
qui comprend quelque chose de leadership
si vous permettez en un seul mot je
crois qu'il ya un problème de leadership
acier un problème de vision et c'est la
vision qui nous fait défaut
on pense toujours que les institutions
sont le point de blocage mais si nous
avions une vision de ce que nous devons
faire de l'europe je crois que l ne
bloquerait plus ceux qui voudraient
vraiment avancer le monde économique
mais le principe d'une entrée
clandestine sur le territoire européen
c'est par définition elle est
clandestine donc quand bien même vous
arriveriez a passé des accords avec les
pays frontaliers l'union européenne pour
y installer ce qu'on appelle des
hotspots
ce qui est loin d'être gagné puisque
pour l'instant les pays ont toujours
refusé mais quand bien même vous y
arriverez y est les les individus qui
désireraient migrer vers l'europe et
qu'ils n'obtiendraient pas l'asile sur
le sol de ces pays là qu'est ce qui les
empêcherait malgré tout de prendre une
route clandestine pour se rendre sur
notre territoire
pourquoi ce serait différent par rapport
à aujourd'hui au fond rien ne les en
empêcherait mais ya un principe simple
que nous devrions pouvoir établir c'est
que celui qui est entré illégalement sur
le sol européen sans en avoir fait la
demande ne peut plus voir instruire une
demande de titre de séjour
ça veut dire que vous délocalisez
l'intégralité de la politique d'asile
européenne dans des pays frontaliers
bien sûr que non ça veut dire que c'est
pas du tout d'ailleurs des camps de
migrants qui s'agitent crée encore une
fois que j'utilisais utiliser le réseau
sera la conséquence probablement mais
c'est parce que nous n'aurons pas du
tout utilisé le réseau consulaire et le
réseau diplomatique pour faire en sorte
que vous puissiez effectivement faire
une demande d'asile
et vous ne puissiez faire une demande
d'asile que sur la route qui vous mène
vers l'europe et ceux ci devraient être
vrai sauf à ce que votre pays soit
immédiatement limitrophes de l'europe
on devrait pouvoir s'accorder sur ce
principe sans quoi le droit d'asile va
devenir ce qu'il est devenu aujourd'hui
malheureusement l'occasion d'un
gigantesque n'importe quoi aujourd'hui
70% qui entre en des personnes qui
entrent en français qui font une demande
ils ne sont pas éligibles à l'asile et
sur ces 70% seulement 4 % sont
effectivement reconduite à l'extérieur
du territoire français ce qui veut bien
dire en fait qu'on utilise le droit
d'asile pour tout autre chose que le
droit d'asile pour détourner ce
processus de solidarité et en faire
l'occasion d'une immigration illégale
que nous ne pouvons plus subir on a vu
les intentions de vote il ya quelques
instants que 13% pour vous est-ce que
vous avez un objectif chiffré est ce que
c'est l'électorat du rassemblement
national que vous allez chercher par
votre discours
bellamy non vous savez je n'ai jamais
cru aux politiques marketing je suis
simplement à un jeune citoyen français
qui s'engage dans ce débat pour essayer
de susciter de nouveau l'adhésion autour
d'un projet et d'un choix
ce que je crois c'est qu'au fond le
clivage pullis progressiste qu'on
voudrait nous imposer ce clivage là ne
ressemblent pas à ceux dont les français
ont besoin
la question n'est pas pour ou contre
l'europe la question c'est qu'est
l'europe voulons nous construire et
j'espère simplement dans cette campagne
avec toute la liste qui m'accompagne
être au service de ce choix des français
pour qu'ils puissent vraiment déterminés
à l'occasion de ce scrutin
l'europe qu'ils attendaient dont ils ont
fait une partie de vos électeurs est
parti aussi chez makro sont pas
seulement au rassemblement national est
ce que vous pouvez leur dire pour leur
dire la mort revenait dont un peu à la
maison
et bien justement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la vision d' emmanuel
macron est très marginal en europe qu'il
est très isolé on l'a vu avec les
réactions à sa lettre aux européens si
on veut que la voix de la france soit
entendu demain il faut qu'elle le soit
au sein d'un groupe politique d'un
groupe parlementaire est aujourd'hui
nathalie l'oiseau ne peut pas nous dire
ne veut pas nous dire où siègeront ces
eurodéputés
c'est pourtant critique pour savoir
comment la france du groupe dans lequel
bien sûr nous nous sommes membre du ppe
et nous pouvons dire aux français
comment et par quels moyens nous allons
faire entendre leur voix dans le débat
européen
merci beaucoup d'être venu s'asseoir sur
ses news